everyone I want to first thank the
organizers for giving me the opportunity
to talk here and i'll be talking about
some work that we recently did this is
with chi minh chung hsiao d woo and this
is about another kind of parallel
repetition we've heard you know from on
KITT you know result about classical
parallel repetition and from tomah about
non signalling parallel repetition this
is about the quantum version and this
uses some what I think is some
interesting ideas from communication
complexity that I think its new so let
me briefly go over the setting again so
we have we start with the two-player one
round game so you have a referee and the
referee will choose questions from some
distribution mu and send them to these
two players Alice and Bob who can't
communicate and the players responded
with answers a and B and they win the
game if X Y a B satisfies some predicate
V okay and how did the players produce
their answers well they use some
strategy and most most generally we can
think of a strategy as just being some
conditional probability distribution you
know for a given input X Y there's some
distribution over a and B and if you're
given a strategy s then you can measure
how well they do with this strategy so
we call this the the value of the
strategy and basically you say well over
the choice of questions from mu how
often can they produce winning answers
so you know given a game G what is the
best that Alice and Bob can do so it
depends on what kind of strategies you
talk about so if you think about
deterministic strategies or classical
strategies then the best you know the
maximum probability they can win is
called the classical value and this is
where you maximize overall strategies
where you know Alice's answer is a fixed
function of her input her question and
Bob similarly answers a fixed
function of his input ok this is the
classical value but we can allow Alice
and Bob to employ more powerful
strategies so imagine that they use
something called quantum entanglement
and it's not important to know what
exactly this is but you know think of
Alice as possessing some particle and
Bob possessing some particle and these
two particles are correlated in very
special ways dictated by the laws of
quantum mechanics and quantum
entanglement if they use this allows
them to produce correlations that
outperform any classical strategy and
when you consider quantum strategy as we
can measure it well the maximum winning
probability to have is what we call the
entangled value of a game
and what's the relationship between
these two values the classical and
entangled value well we know that the
classical value is at most the the
quantum value you can you can do at
least as well if you're allowed quantum
strategies but we know of games where
there actually is a separation so for
example this CH SH game classically you
can do no better than winning three
quarters of the time but if Alice and
Bob share quantum entanglement they can
produce answers that win about
eighty-five percent of the time so
quantum strategy strategies are more
powerful ok so let's talk about the
pedlar repetition of game if you start
with a game G you can repeat it in this
very natural way to try to make it
harder so you know the referee will
choose an independent question pairs
from the original distribution and send
them to Alice and Bob simultaneously and
they have to produce n answers all at
the same time and they win this repeated
game if they win each of the individual
games ok so we've seen this before and
then the fundamental question about
parallel repetition is well how does the
value of this repeated game compared you
know behave as a function of the
original game value and the number of
repetitions you take so we know of
counter examples that it doesn't behave
as nicely as we want it to so we know
games for example G its value is
one-half but if you repeat it twice the
maximum winning probability is still one
half so it's not true that the value of
G you know this repeated game is the
original value raised to the nth power
it's more complicated than that but we
still have an exponential decay and this
is known as the parallel repetition
theorem is first proved by Ron roz
simplified by Thomas Rowland Stein and
extended by Mark and on kids recently
and you know the value of this repeated
game the classical value is upper
bounded by some complicated function of
you know the output alphabet size and
epsilon where the original
value of the game is 1 minus epsilon
okay but the important thing is that the
value of this repeated game still goes
down exponentially with the number of
repetitions okay but you know we're
talking about quantum games so we can
ask the same question about the
entangled value so if you do this
parallel repetition of G you know how
does the entangled value of G to the end
behave as a function of the original
entangled value you know the question is
does the repeated entangled value also
disk it indicate exponentially an N or
does it decay at all and for general
games G this is not known surprisingly
but we do know some things and in the
past couple of years of there have been
some partial results and I just want to
highlight you know it last year the most
relevant to this talk we do have
parallel repetition theorems for
entangled games but for special classes
of games and those two special classes
are what are called free games so these
are games where the questions to Alice
and Bob are independent and okay so mu
of X Y is a product distribution and we
have this exponential decay that's like
the classical case we also have from
dinner store vidiq that also for
projection games we also have a quantum
parallel repetition theorem
so our main result that we prove is we
focus also on the case of free games so
product input distribution and we prove
that the entangled value of this
repeated game decays like 1 minus
epsilon to the three-halves raised to
the power of you know and over s where s
is the length of allison Bob's answers
okay so you know how is this a result
well it it's a better upper bound on the
repeated game value than what was known
previously and so what's different here
is that the power on epsilon is
different it's better we save a factor
of square root epsilon and this is the
bound that was obtained by Jane at all
and show you in scarpa last year okay so
you know it's a better bound but what's
the big deal we just went from a base of
1 minus epsilon squared 2 1 minus
epsilon to the three-halves you know
what's to write home about well i find
this interesting for two reasons and the
first is we don't know of a classical
analog okay people have thought about
parallel repetition not only in general
but in the case of free games and
perhaps the most interesting reason i
think is our proof uses some new tools
from quantum communication complexity so
let's talk about the classical case in
09 Boas Barack anoop Ron Roz Ricky Rosen
runnin she'll tell proved this result
that's somewhat similar to ours that for
a free game G the classical you know
players Alice and Bob who only used
classical strategies the decay and the
entangled value is 1 minus epsilon
squared raised to the N over s ok is
this tight we don't really know except
we know that other types of games on
this Ron showed for projection games
this squared you know this to exponent
is necessary ok so it's possible that
this bound that
baraka at all is also tight and if this
is so then this would indicate that
there's some separation between how
games behave you know quantum games and
classical games behave under parallel
repetition okay and and so you can think
of this as we've sort of obtained a
quantum speed-up of parallel repetition
so we've shown a better upper bound on
the entangled value of this repeated
game and we show that it goes to zero
faster with the number of repetitions
and in order to get this quantum
speed-up we leverage a pretty novel
connection between communication
complexity and parallel repetition that
was introduced by shall you and scarpa
so I mean historically if you look at
the proofs of you know they say the
classical parallel repetition theorem
there are a lot of commonalities between
that and the way people prove
communication lower bounds like namely
that of disjoint pneus but their
connection they use an explicit
communication protocol in order to
analyze this repeated game value so in
their paper i'll describe you know how
you use communication protocols to
analyze parallel repetition but i want
to say that in their paper they use a
very basic communication protocol okay
but it's good enough to obtain this
bound and in our work we use a faster
quantum communication protocol okay and
because it's you know not only is it
because it's quantum but it uses fewer
bits of communication is why we save on
this epsilon the exponent of epsilon and
basically the you know to give away the
punch line why is it fast well we use a
distributed version of the growver
search algorithm in this protocol and
what is that algorithm well it's it says
that you can search an unordered list of
n items for some marked item in time
square root n okay and it's this
quadratic savings in search time that
allows us to save this square root
epsilon
okay and so you know I find this
interesting for a bunch of reasons it's
a new technique for approving parallel
repetition maybe even more intuitive and
this is an example of a phenomenon of
better upper bounds yielding better
lower bounds and complexity theory and
you know and we over the last several
decades we've spent a lot of time
building better and better communication
protocols making them faster more robust
so on and so we can hopefully draw upon
that rich toolbox of techniques that
people have worked on to prove these
direct product and direct some theorems
and you know I think it's somewhat
timely because you know we have a motto
and these days a lot of people are
announcing that run for presidency and
you know they're announcing complaints
campaign slogans so if we were to run
for office this would be our campaign
slogan better parallel repetition
theorems from better communication
protocols okay so how do communication
protocols come into play so let me walk
you through a high-level proof outline
of how you prove parallel repetition so
you start with a two player game G and
it has entangled value 1 minus epsilon
so the high-level proof idea is you take
a two good strategy s for this repeated
game and you convert it to a strategy T
for the original game that does better
than 1 minus epsilon which would be a
contradiction and the most natural way
to do this is if you get you know
single-game inputs X and Y you embed
them in some coordinate of this global
strategy you know you sort of pretend
that you're playing this repeated game
and you insert your inputs into some
coordinate I conditioned on some event w
where you know if you play the strategy
condition on this event w the
probability that you win this coordinate
I
is greater than 1 minus epsilon so
that's the high-level idea but let me
make it a little more precise so you
know let's let boldface letters indicate
you know inputs and outputs for the
repeated game so let's say there's an
optimal strategy for G to the M and it's
a quantum strategy so Alice and Bob
shares some entanglement and they make
some measurements and so on and let's
say that the entangled value of this
repeated game is 2 to the minus gamma n
and our goal is to show that this gamma
is large so we want to show that this
entangle value it looks like 2 to the
minus n ish so the goal you know of this
embedding stated in this these terms
will Alice and Bob if they're given x
and y they would like to simulate this
repeated game strategy conditioned on
you know X I being this little x and y I
being little I also condition on w and
they want to simulate this without any
communication so in general you know is
it possible to do the simulation without
communication you know not generally but
there sufficient conditions for for this
to be possible and these are the
sufficient conditions that both shall
you and scarpa and jane at all came up
with and it's some mutual information
conditions and what are they intuitively
saying they say that well suppose you
look at you know Alice and Bob they play
play you know the strategy s and you
condition on this event w you know how
much information does Bob side of the
entanglement along with his inputs have
about some coordinate of X I you know
one of Alice's inputs and vice versa you
know how much does Alice know you know
her entanglement how much information
does that know about why I one of Bob's
questions and if these two quantities
are small
then you can do the simulation with some
small error and they can do this without
any communication so we just have to
prove that these mutual information
quantities are small and the way that
shadow and scarpa do it is will they
give an efficient communication protocol
to generate this system and also
determine whether this event w happened
and since the communication protocols
efficient in turn implies that the
mutual information is small ok good so
EA represents like Alice's part of the
entanglement so it's some quantum system
and we can use mutual information to
measure how much knowledge it has about
X classical measurement right so this is
quantum states so this is quantum mutual
information but right so this I mean
definitely you need the freeness
condition because otherwise why we'll
have some mutual information with X I
wire I and X are correlated so yeah this
is what you know big place where we need
this is where you used remus I yeah this
is a big place where we use
so you know what's down line while you
you start with a to good strategy s for
this repeated game and since it's too
good it implies the existence of an
efficient communication protocol to
determine whether this event w happened
and since its efficient you can use it
to bound the mutual information so the
protocol goes as follows Alice and Bob
they get their repeated inputs they play
the game and they engage in some short
conversation such that by the end they
want to be able to conclude with high
confidence whether this event w happened
and if we can show that this
communication is short the mutual
information is and then this implies the
information is small by the sufficient
conditions i just described we have a
very good strategy for the single game
because we can do the simulation so you
know let me say what this event w is so
in Chaouen scarpa it's the event that if
we choose a random subset of rounds of
games call it C and it's not too large
and then we look at did they win in all
these rounds and see ok and if they'd
won in all of them then we say the event
w happened ok so if this subset is of a
certain size its gamma and over epsilon
where gammas are related to our winning
probability then if you look at a random
coordinate outside of C then with very
good probability they will win this
coordinate ok so this event w satisfies
what we need now we just have to show
that there's a short communication
protocol for figuring out whether w
happened so what's their communication
protocol it's pretty straightforward so
what Alice and Bob do is in the
beginning that you shared randomest to
pick this set C and they also using
public randomness choose what the inputs
are to these game rounds
and then else will privately sample the
rest of our inputs Bob will privately
sample the rest of his inputs and they
can do this because we're assuming that
the game input distribution is product
they can do this independently they then
you know play this game strategy which
in general will only you know they only
win all the rounds with exponentially
small probability but no matter now they
didn't want to do this checking so Alice
will send all our answers that she
obtained in the sea rounds and she sends
them to Bob and then Bob just checks
okay so that's the communication
protocol so what good does this do us so
what's the communication complexity the
only time they talked was in step 4
Alice sends a sea of our answers so you
know c times the answer length so that's
the communication complexity and this
gives us a bound on the mutual
information so we can imagine that
before they've talked before step 4 you
know how much information does Bob's
part of the entanglement have about any
of Alice's inputs other than this
publicly sampled XC and it should be 0
because Alice sampled these inputs
independently so bob has no information
so the only way that he could have
acquired some information is through
this communication but we're assuming
that it's small and so the mutual
information condition on W is at most
you know some constant times the number
of bits that were sent in this
communication protocol and vice versa
and this holds even conditioned on this
event
so you apply the normal chain rule and
this implies that if the if Q is small
then Bob's knowledge of some X I should
be Q over N and this is some quantity
gamma s over Epsilon okay so what does
that mean by our sufficient conditions
that means that Alice and Bob can do
this you know embedding without
communication with this amount of error
but this implies that we have a strategy
that wins with 1 minus 0 of epsilon and
that's because how we chose this event w
and we subtract off the error due to the
simulation and we get a contradiction
when this gamma is less than epsilon
squared over the answer length so this
is how shall you and scarpa prove this 1
minus epsilon squared bound
so we want to prove a better bound so we
want to get a contradiction when gamma
is larger so when gamma can go all the
way up to epsilon 2 3 halves but if you
run it through this shy you scarpa
protocol the communication complexity it
would be too much it'd be square root
epsilon times n so we can't argue that
this mutual information is is little so
our solution is to use this faster
protocol to grow research like I
mentioned so you can think of it you
know what is their protocol doing
they're just searching for this round in
the subset see where they might have
lost right so you know if you're
restricting yourself to classical
protocols they have to exchange at least
see bits of communication right because
that's how many rounds they want to
check but let's take advantage of
growver search ok so in Grove research
you have n items you can find a marked
one using square root and queries and X
exceeds with constant probability and
the idea is well instead of doing
classical search let's have Bob run
Grover's algorithm to search for such a
losing coordinate if it if there exists
one and whenever Bob needs to know what
the value of AJ is you know this is
Alice's answering the J around Bob will
just communicate with Allison say tell
me what AJ is and so the hope here is
the number of time that Bob needs to
query is should be about square root C
so I mean that's the hope but can we
actually get it the communication to
that low not quite because this Grover
search only works with two-thirds of
probability and we actually need
something that has extremely small error
exponentially small error but we can fix
this with some amplification tricks but
the general idea is to use Grover search
so what's our communication protocol
it's essentially the same so they use
shared randomness to pick this subset
see but then they break it up into
blocks of size 1 over epsilon ok so
constant size blocks so Alison Bob play
their strategy and now they want to do
this check so for each of the blocks Bob
will run Grover search on you know this
one over epsilon size block but when you
do that the amount of communication he
has to perform is 1 over square root
epsilon ok and he just does this for
every block and they just look for a
losing coordinate and if there's no
losing coordinate they accept so you
know what's the difference here well the
communication complexity is the number
of blocks times 1 over square root
epsilon times this alphabet size and the
key point is now that the denominator
here is this square root epsilon it's a
bigger denominator so we've saved on the
communication and if you run it through
since we have less communication we can
prove a better upper bound on this on
our winning probability so that's how we
get 1 minus epsilon to the three halves
and that's essentially the proof
I wish I just okay great so there's some
technical details so we don't run Grover
naively we have to use something called
the aronson a- protocol which is a
protocol for disjoining this and we have
a couple of other results we can extend
our proof to handle multiple players not
just two and we also have results for
parallel repetition of games where Alice
and Bob produced quantum states as
answers and this might have some future
applications to quantum PCP conjectures
if we ever get there and perhaps you
know in terms of open questions the
biggest question is what's the right
answer for free games you know
classically is the epsilon squared tight
or can we do better or is there actually
a quantum classical separation thank you
is the cherries concealed stock with you
okay right so so somehow epsilon to the
three-halves doesn't seem like the right
number but on the other hand classically
I don't know you get the sense that
epsilon squared is is the right answer
so I think there's a separation but
maybe quantumly you can get actually 1
minus epsilon
here we show that the Buncombe value of
the game can defer from the classical
ballet with their in the right so we
know of there's a huge separation when
you measure in terms of distance from
one half I don't can't think of the top
of my head where one is close to one and
the other is extremely close to zero oh
no no no the Quantum's 10 like the magic
square game I guess no this is uh we
stop yourself when the quantum is one
right classical computer to use to must
asleep oh that's right yeah right
for questions hey let's thank Henry